please welcome henry winkler
it is so nice to see you i just wish i
was there to give you a hug
i wish that i was there to give you a
hug
because when i met you
when i was young you actually
changed my life forever because the
fawns the most important
like man on the planet was nice
i was like then everybody has to be nice
because the fonz is nice
and you always everyone around
i would clock the way you treated people
and
there was something about your kindness
that made me
know that that was like the marching
order of life
and that is one of the most wonderful
compliments i've ever gotten uh you know
i i never
think of being nice i think of being
grateful
i think that i am so uh happy
that i get to do what i dreamt of doing
and that it is
it has grown over the years you know you
talk about the fawns i got the fawns on
my 27th birthday
and i got barry on my 72nd
birthday and in very few days
i'm going to be 74. which is really
hard to say uh you know because inside
you don't feel it but
my knees my knees are 75. yes
i my yes my lower back is like 89.
um but it's true you get older and your
number starts going up and then
what you thought seemed like an older
number doesn't because
true when i was younger i would think
75 they have you know
i don't know what they are they but here
i am
and i have this wonderful uh knock on
wood
full life i have a beautiful family
uh i get to do the work that i love to
do
and i also then get to work with
um lynn oliver and here it is i mean
i i cannot even tell you that my name is
on a book let alone many
is insane to me may i ask
what sort of was the light bulb
moment where you realized that you
wanted to have your name on a book
because you felt like you wanted to
write a book
what a great question because there was
no moment
a man named alan said to me hey there's
a low
in your acting career why don't you
write books for children
about your learning challenge and i said
because i have a learning challenge
because people told me i was stupid
i can't write a book he introduced me to
lynn oliver
who knew everything about children's
literature
and it was easy for me to at
whatever age i think we started writing
when i was 57
to remember what it was like to be eight
and
fail all the time really try
really think oh my goodness i i know
these words why can i not remember them
when the test is happening
i remembered how it felt is it true that
you were diagnosed with dyslexia
yes my oldest son jed my stepson who
came
as a uh a beautiful gift with the
marriage
we had him tested in the third grade and
everything that they said about him was
true about me
and i realized i wasn't stupid oh my my
parents
uh i've said this before but they used
to call me duma
and if you don't speak german that means
dumb dog very
very supportive very supportive people
uh
very little sense of humor and then i
realized i had something with a name
i love that you can go and
channel a feeling that you had
when you were younger yeah isn't that
the definition of
empathy i would tell you that uh the
first time when i came from new york to
hollywood the first job i had
i had four lines on the mary tyler moore
show which was the friends
of its time yes and they said lunch
and all of these big stores they all
went to lunch and i just
was in the middle of the sound stage and
i had no idea where to go no one had
told me
and i s you know you you you i felt
really
alone and i swore
i would never let anybody on a set i was
on
feel that way ever again
and no matter what show i do if there is
a guest
i take that guest man or woman by the
hand
and show them where they can get
anything done during the day we have an
ongoing segment here called
in the loop um with our one of our
favorite correspondence jonah larson
and he loves to read more than anyone i
know
and hi jonah can you see us
i can hide you i'm so excited matter of
fact i made myself a crochet sweater
just for the occasion oh my god
did you whip that up like yeah how long
did that take you
about a day well